We would expect the assignment of local variables to be the very fastest.
Shared memory is also very fast.
A and b are both shared memory variables, so you would expect that to be fast.
Global variables are all the way out in global memory, so they're going to be the slowest.
We would expect that this assignment of the contents of y to the contents of z
is probably the slowest operation.
And this one, which is moving a piece of data from global memory into shared memory,
is probably the second slowest.
By the way, if you know anything about compilers, you realize that this is an oversimplification.
Right? It's quite possible that many of these values will be promoted into registers.
An optimizing compiler might rearrange accesses and so forth.
But the point is simply to get across the relative speeds of memories.